Brooksie mom Roxy one Roxy one I not
expected
Roxy one OK by force an ant will take
pawn on but he will activate White's
King he will give some more options I
don't like his move now
Carlson seems better after king of two
rooks it there too
King g3 rook take a four-night egg g v
a5 King F 3 a4 Bishop d6 Kinney 1 sorry
I stopped my kin even immediately yes
sir okay - yes Bishop d6 was predicted
is now an ant in trouble what time I
will stop c5 pawn even by King on by
Bishop and take g5 only 6 a 5 should
play and maybe he underestimate
overestimate his chances should take on
e3 by logical kin even okay - Bishop d6
kin f7 now may 5 we shop d6 Bishop d6 a
590 g5 a for what else now for Carlson
is some option maybe some maybe King D 1
also all champion can play try to catch
stop spawn to help King now spectators
the president of Egyptian Federation yes
in the center in suit yes kindiy 1 yes
right cousin played kin d1 and not only
Carson playing for in this position very
strange decision was for former world
champion
a three teensy one maybe rook g2 bishop
take a three so I guess it will be like
endgame rook and pawn against two pieces
and on d5 again strokin rook on d5
against two pieces and pond if I rugby
to some trick maybe some tactical trick
I didn't see what's his idea and idea
but I believe some trick he has what
about King c1 maybe some off like nah he
stopped 96 first 96 rugby too
let what happen a fork in d1 rugby -
sorry rugby - what - Blake in c1 her b3
maybe idea Magnus Carlsen took suddenly
what I don't believe he blundered what
what what what is his move
what is 96
what's idea 95 maybe some tactic but
what about a three what he miss my looks
he misses something yes my face not
happy miss it and now seems he misses
remove I don't even guess what he miss
it
some big blunder for world such player
like Magnus Carlsen rugby six he miss it
very easy attack for two pieces for key
I don't know if for comp in yes two
pieces he lost look his face unhappy yes
this is a significant moment in game
what to play how to stop enhance
unbelievable unbelievable luck for
Vishwanathan Anand now he has chance to
became leader of this tournament okay 94
cars and play truck take d6 King c2 root
b6 how to stop this pawn Knight takes d5
maybe ace yes like a kin C - maybe
Magnus Carlsen will make draw if he
we'll come on b2 on a three it seems he
will make draw maybe so this game he
didn't deserve slows rook takes rook
where ugh b7 very experienced
Vishwanathan Anand yes some very good
also practical decision he is Knight c3
a3 Ruby 7 here Knight c3 cutting cutting
he writes he has no idea rook c1 and
rock somewhere and a - what to play now
only an ant now playing for win by
carlson's big blunder big blunder in c1
on e4 e for yes
what about rugby to check in see van
rook G - King be one group D to rugby to
in C one rogue G to King V 1 ok vote for
an ant or brink ink
bring in on f7 world champion former
world champ magnus carlsen big blunder
for Magnus Carlsen now the five king
will block ii v kini six and maybe g v
g5 King e6 in F 75 in e6 kin see one
what's idea need to play rugby three
maybe rugby three in situ
nor be three in situ how to stop maybe
rogue d77 don't guess but why not rogue
d7 I cannot take maybe Rock the seven
with some trap night b-58 - sorry
92 in b2 o b7
Keeney six four minutes 25 seconds
against four minutes at the same time
after Carlson's big blunder and I'm
trying to win this match what to play
rugby 3 rugby to work d7 g7 rock c7
hindi to only move because skin C 2 was
losing by King by a 2 now black side EMA
White's idea to bring keen on d3 kindy
to position very dangerous but maybe
most important pawn on d4 is still alive
so how to stop broke a 792 are ok for
and kin d5 very difficult rock a7 Magnus
Carlsen rugby 7 yes conceive am most
probably in series losing or not you can
see one or consistency one most probably
consistory Ruby 291 yes in c3
can not play night before because roof
take before very difficult position for
cows and I didn't see direct win for
Anand but very very difficult rogue be
to night see one live on Iranian play
three minutes 20 and against for our
Anant and for 24 magnus carlsen round 12
for volt rapid championship all total it
will play will be play 15 rounds what to
play king d5 rugby to rugby - maybe he
intend to play rugby to rugby to night
see one some move by row quiz idea a -
to promote pole
rogue people root b8 waiting move if I
wait for example some can I waive my
waiting move while it's waiting must be
like g5f waiting mo strange waiting move
whisking a 5 g 6 idea to try to push
past pawns best pawn should push it so
king c3 rogue b8 what to play g5 what is
night c1 maybe some check unpleasant
check on c7 thought about other moves
maybe g5 no and g6 and even sacrifice
one point to push another 2-3 minutes 20
against 226 cults and now less than 1
minute ahead led to make my brief yes
buddy
what about car 1 Utama g5 of course kini
5 Caruana Tomaszewski kuranes looks
better you youngji against Iranian
position very complicated but looks you
and give faster g5 e 5 check some tricks
maybe found like g6 yes he never died 6
and to deflect ro can take pawn on b3
yes kindy v g7 maybe he misses something
g7 playing - very confident now what I
remember it should be drawn but how
night before rock tech before so can I
catch I should give promote night
promote Queen here like this is six take
yes now White's to move
maybe losing Queen trea
what now
kindiy father where is idea king before
Luke g3 night c1
but what night b3 I will go by king no
Carlson big blunder big blunder and
Anand became leader of tornami this is
losing position in before in d5 Knight
check in default check but even here I
am playing King III hockey how it skinny
593 King before I cannot play in rook is
really right seems hopeless position for
Carlson King b3 kindy fall in c4 cut
King Cain f5 he is gone the two most
probably there is some more 5 the guess
work in d4 rookie two and a to promote
Queen so what to play for cows in before
back
1:48 position difficult in before on the
chance for an ins help in g4 he is going
from D to now first lost maybe coming by
an ant will drink some drink is some no
yes losing position for Magnus Carlsen
92 in f3 Knight c3 in Knight c3 kingi to
gain is running slow but on chest and
right way maybe resigned Magnus Carlsen
cannot stop an idea 95 95 rock f3 Knight
c3 King the flam King coming like train
on time in c4 anyone
Hiroki three waiting to move
yes resign magnus carlsen here yes and
of course very nervous lives